all right here we go what do you got for
me rough stuff
hey what's going on rich yeah that's
good i wanted to jump on here because i
wanted to kind of like share my
experience a little bit all right you
got a story for me and um yeah so
basically um i went through the whole
grinder in the past you know i did like
professional gaming um
and i ended up meeting my ex my ex ended
up uh going after me you know in the
past
um i noticed that over time when i had
kids um when i started doing my work
online with um the gaming community i
was judged a lot
and that kind of judgment basically
brought me down into
i would say the 1000 you know
concessions of beta ization betazation
by a thousand sessions yeah it's one of
the references i made in my book
and uh basically um through that entire
process i changed from having that
strong mindset to having a weak mindset
i used to be the one who was like hey
we're gonna go here we're gonna go do
this and then it started getting down to
um you know after i had kids um
hey uh your choice where you wanna go
you know what i mean
um
i got fat i got um i tried to get back
into shape i started going back to the
gym but because i was out of shape i sat
on my ass all the time
playing games i didn't stretch i ended
up getting sciatica and then my wife
ended up leaving me because i was just
basically injured um i could not sit for
a long time um i was overweight
and what ended up happening is after
that i went through this whole entire
process where
i was like man you know it's my fault
what did i do wrong you know
i love this woman to death
and so
for about a year it took me about a year
i was going through a phase of hey am i
going to go this polygamous route am i
going to get screwed around by these
boss all the time um
and
at one point i just put my foot down and
i'm like i can't do this you know it's
against my morals
um so now i couldn't do what exactly
though um i couldn't pursue that route
basically the beta route you know what i
mean
you know getting a stamp card of trying
to please a woman in order to you know
get something out of them
um so
i decided to start focusing on myself
started focusing on my health i started
watching your videos i started watching
like sterling uh started watching rolo
and i started getting like a better
mindset i'm like hey this is what i used
to be a long time ago this is how i got
my ex this is how you know
um i didn't i didn't have money back
then but i looked good so
um
but basically
i started utilizing those tools
in real life recently
and um
let's just say i decided to pursue a
friend of mine's co-worker
and she decided to join with us and i
used like sterling's tips and i was like
hey you know i put my leg up against her
when we were having a good conversation
and immediately this woman started
feeding me she started cutting the steak
giving me the food i was like what is
going on here then we go out to the bar
and then she's just kissing up all on me
you know
um it really shows that if you put in
the hard work and effort uh you you go
through the misery i went through that
the entire time
i was questioning myself and
i gotta say that yourself
uh your compadres out there they helped
me out a lot how old are you now
um 36.
so
like you can't judge darkness without
light right
right same you know it's the same thing
the other way around too right like you
can't judge what's what's bright without
darkness so you've managed to go through
the both of those things
and you're going to start to notice you
know if things go dark again on you like
if they start to you know if you start
to go through a beta tizzation process i
mean as long as you're aware and you're
unplugged then you're going to notice it
you're going to control it right so
that's really what
that that whole thing you know distills
itself down to really is okay well if
you're unplugged then you got to unplug
for life right because there's going to
be conditions that you're going to get
into let's say you get into another
relationship or something like that
it turns into something longer term
you are going to inevitably receive
inputs that are going to try to beta
ties you through a thousand concessions
which you're gonna have to hold firm on
and have frame right so that's what we
were talking about you know before with
john as well too and that's that's just
a concept that guys have to understand
the burden of performance is on men to
manage that relationship you can't defer
well what do you want to eat tonight i
don't know what do you want to eat i
don't care what do you want to eat
tonight what do you want it's like that
goes nowhere fast yep
right
so it's like we're going to get this get
in the car wear the black dress that i
like it's time for dinner right like
that's what women want and that's
truthfully what men want to be
anyway thanks for sharing that man
yeah and thank you appreciate it take
care bro
you